hello and welcome to this video playing
correct releases so after that last game
I actually show you stop the session but
I'm really too much heat on getting my
rating back to normal level so I keep
keep playing and see what happens so
I've got this line again the end up in
the bank oh yeah this is a even more
harmless version than usual get the
night over to be five maybe Bishop g5
now could be an issue and one can take
between so it doesn't work what can take
be too
[Music]
yes I can go look before amongst others
so cannot cannot save f8 but don't have
time to just take stuff
yeah I'm losing that game again I'm
going to quit the session really edit
that's that's that's useless then people
give you a winning position like after
ten moves or 12 moves or something no it
was not 1216 still you don't win so
let's see you let's convert this he has
to take whatever eight anyway what's
what's the point here okay I nite ch Wow
and so 96 f 8
[Music]
Wow so can I do here I mean I don't
think this is particularly bad I just
failed I I should have something better
I just don't just didn't see anything ok
so here maybe just night 25 bishop age 6
27 let's do if you want to play let's do
it again if it doesn't work I mean I
just deserve to be punished Bishop age 6
37 what's my dear I also could just take
I could have just taken f8 then you have
a couple of extra pawns as well
[Music]
probably i'm getting made it on g7
somehow in some extremely wacky fashion
yeah that's kind of what I expected no
no I did not have a fantastic reply to
it and maybe queen age six was good
attacking and attacking age too
[Music]
[Music]
ok it's not that bad i can always like
f3 i can go back to you six
[Music]
if she threatening something see it's up
push it
[Music]
looks a bit inconvenient
yeah mm-hmm I've moved it back a success
hanging this looks a little bit wrong
don't see why exactly what does it look
like the best move anyway don't want to
spend more time and then at the end
rules on time
the point is almost hanging with him
should you
[Music]
deform and 95 looks good
[Music]
you know both look both look good hi
morning Jenna got more time actually
here just nice so should we should age
six still on the cards I can play Queen
f6 though
check oh that I didn't expect check
check check check check check check mate
has always kind of unnerving at it okay
tick tick stuff which the blunder and
then there's still some kind of counter
plane yep so this is this opening line
yeah I'm pretty happy with this kind of
position and that this this just doesn't
work I think I mean not not well at
least so take him and this one yeah
mediately taking you to it I don't think
this was bad there should be seven take
this teen tween cakes and this yeah this
was a shocker yeah this is really funny
right the really funny point this is
actually mate so losing the Queen
so this yeah now interesting 95 I think
I also could have done that I guess so I
saw this variation check and I didn't
really feel like he has much and the
computer confirms yeah I wasn't sure
this this looks more complicated but I
also thought it looks better yeah so the
engine is basically okay with my play
didn't miss anything in particular up to
here check yeah you three go to check
yeah I think it's okay i think it's okay
the computer doesn't find anything
anything special you have white anymore
mini still as those wake swindling
chances but from four pawns up so it
doesn't really feel dangerous one thing
about is opening I think black gets in
this is almost always very fine in the
spanker structure as the light squared
Bishop is that you useless piece okay
thanks for watching